Alain signot Le Maire de Beaune
responsable de l'IMP en Côte-d'Or il
s'est créé tout à l'heure on écoute
Alain süno ça aurait pu 1983 l'époque on
avait un slogan j'étais jeune président
du RPR dans la Nièvre à l'époque de
François mitter et Pierre Bérégovoy et à
l'époque on disait la reconquête
commence par les villes et quand on
regarde le calendrier avec bien
évidemment l'année prochaine et puis
c'est l'intérieur en septembre on est à
peu près dans le même scénario donc
c'est vrai qu'il y a aujourd'hui une
vague mais cette vague elle correspond
simplement au désamour des Françaises et
des Français avec le gouvernement
d'aujourd'hui y compris François
Hollande je crois que le message est
très clair par contre le message il est
aussi valable pour nous je crois que ça
veut dire que c'est de dire on vous
donne un chèque il est pas en blanc
arrêté entre guillemets les difficultés
qu'on a pu connaître l'an dernier les
querelles de personnes on voit
d'ailleurs que quand il y a eu des
querelle quelque part
l'union fait la force et quand il y a
une désunion on ne gagne pas forcément
et je pense que ce message là c'est
aussi un message d'alternance je crois
qu'il faut l'entendre 5 sur 5 et je fais
partie de ceux qui l'entendent bien
évidemment pour c'est vrai que c'est une
déferlante quand on regarde bien bon
sors de Dijon et bien sûr un peu
différent mais je pense que François
hepsomen ce soir a eu très chaud quand
même parce que c'est vrai que 52 et
quelques c'est quand même pour un maire
sortant qui est au surplus je l'ai
toujours dit j'ai toujours pas parlé qui
n'est pas n'importe qui je crois que il
paye plein pot bien évidemment son
appartement socialiste et puis également
probablement le fait de sa présence de
groupe au Sénat donc il y a vote
sanction y compris contre lui et puis il
y a bien sûr sur l'ensemble du
territoire d'agot d'or je suis un
président du MP plutôt heureux parce que
quand on regarde bien toutes les villes
tombent les unes après les autres y
compris des villes alors je pense à nos
voisins de sauter là aussi
Nevers que je connais bien le musée tout
à l'heure Nevers qui tombent ce soir ça
fait quand même près de 40 ans qu'on a
pas vu ça je crois que ce 7 sanctions le
Parti socialiste de l'apprendre en tant
que tel mais je crois qu'il appartient
aussi pour nos couleurs de montrer
l'exemple et de se dire après tout c'est
un message qui est fort il faut bien sûr
l'entendre